es sind tödlicher als hai angriffe und
dank einer neuen statistik wissen wir
jetzt mehr über den schrecklichen tod
los geht's mit blick zum tanzen fiction
49 menschenleben hat die lust auf 111
schon gekostet diese nachricht hat vor
kurzem self fotografen aufhorchen lassen
also nahezu jeden jetzt ist eine
statistik veröffentlicht worden die
aufschlüsselt wer zu den todesopfern
zählen wo sie herkam was genau die
todesursache war und so weiter und so
fort statistik ist schon eine
aufschlussreiche wissenschaft saves gibt
es eine ganze menge bei facebook
instagram oder snapshot werden sie ohne
ende hochgeladen und die likes dafür
eingesammelten statistik wissen wir bei
instagram wurde über 50 millionen mal
der hashtags helfe benutzt 30 prozent
aller bilder die von 18 bis 24 jährigen
gemacht werden sind es elf und vielen
reiche es schon lange nicht mehr einfach
nur ein bild von sich selbst beim
frühstück im kino oder in der bahn zu
machen um mehr aufmerksamkeit zu bekommt
begeben sich viele leute in waghalsige
situationen in denen sie sich sogar in
lebensgefahr bringen seit 2014 hat es
durch riskante versuche ein
spektakuläres elfi zu machen
49 tote geben was für eine zahl und wie
absurd tödliches selbst fotografieren
auf der seite des unternehmenspreises
dass ich mit datenauswertung beschäftigt
hat man anhand der google news suche
ausgewertet sowie vielen todesfällen es
in verschiedenen situationen gekommen
ist ja zum beispiel im letzten jahr also
2015 sind 17 menschen auf dem mount
everest gestorben 28 kam beim unfall
beim skateboarden ums leben und durch
saves da sind es auch 28 bei salamis hat
sich dieses phänomen dann genauer
ansehen letztes jahr schon gegen der
vergleich der todeszahlen durch self eis
und hai attacken durch die presse und
hat für aufsehen gesorgt die zahl der
opfer durch hai attacken liegt laut der
liste von promis bei 8 also 20 tote
weniger als durch sex wie sind die leute
beim fotografieren eigentlich um kommen
auch da hilft die statistik scheint
wirklich sehr riskant zu sein ein tolles
elfi zu machen
die auswertung der daten hat ergeben
dass 16 menschen starben weil sie von
irgendwo runtergefallen sind eine
sensationelle
aus sicht ist ja auch verlocken erst
letzte woche sind ein paar leute den
kölner dom hoch geklettert um da oben
ein video zu drehen und das war nicht
der erste fall von illegaler kletterei
auf den dom auch im jahr 2013 wurde er
bestiegen und auch damals wurden fotos
gemacht der trend nennt sich rufen die
ufer wollen immer spektakulärere bilder
machen und klettern illegal auf vor
gebäude vor allem in russland ist fink
beliebt allerdings auch nicht illegal
anders als bei uns bei uns ist das
klettern auf fremde gebäude
hausfriedensbruch und kann mit einer
geldstrafe oder sogar gefängnis bestraft
werden und passt man ich richtig
aufsetzt eine fuß falsch feldmann von
gebäuden oder klippen in den tod
statistisch gesehen verlaufen stürze
unter zehn metern fallhöhe und ab 25
metern fallhöhe am tödlichsten statistik
sei dank schon bei höhe von zehn metern
erreicht der menschliche körper eine
geschwindigkeit von rund 50 kilometern
pro stunde und bei dieser fallhöhe aber
auch darunter können verletzungen am
kopf oder auch innere verletzungen zum
tod führen in indien stürzte ein mann
lediglich die stufen des touch mal
hinunter als er gerade 111 ii machen
wollte er erlag später seinen
verletzungen
und der instagram user traffic starb
er stürzte neun stockwerke tief als er
versuchte ein bild zu machen
der russe wurde nur 17 jahre alt ein
vermeintlich weiteres spektakuläres
motiv ist 111 vor einem herannahenden zu
gewiss was jetzt kommt je näher der zug
dran ist desto besser oder desto
schlimmer so zumindest die einstellung
derjenigen die solche saves machen
wollen
beim bremsweg von 400 bis 1000 metern
ist es für lokführer unmöglichen solchen
situationen den zug rechtzeitig zum
stehen zu bringen oft ist es auch schwer
die geschwindigkeit eines zuges
abzuschätzen so kann er sich sehr viel
schneller nähern als man das erwartet
das kann allerdings auch sein dass man
mit den stromleitungen der bahn in
kontakt kommt und so durch den
stromschlag ums leben koch statistik
ergebnis elf im zusammenhang bezügen
haben acht leute das leben gekostet und
das sind die weiteren registrierten
todesarten vier tote hat es durch
unfälle mit handfeuerwaffen gegeben zwei
starben sogar durch granaten 2 bei
flugzeugunglücken und auch zwei bei
autounfällen und einer durch ein tier
dank der statistik wissen wir auch wo er
die todesopfer kommen russland
verzeichnet neun tote im zusammenhang
mit cfs und steht damit auf dem zweiten
platz weltweit auf dem ersten platz ist
indien hier starben sogar 19 menschen
grund für die vielen toten hier ist der
zweite platz der häufigsten
todesursachen durch self die unfälle
ertrinken 14 menschen hat das das leben
gekostet viele menschen in indien können
nicht schwimmen
häufig auch stürzen menschen von klippen
wenn sie versuchen vor dort aus ein bild
zu machen und trinken dann im meer auf
dem dritten platz der meistens elf toten
liegen die usa fünf menschen kamen hier
ums leben und dann kommt erst das erste
europäische land vier tote gab es in
spanien wer genau lässt sich statistisch
gesehen zu solchen riskanten aktionen
hinreißen laut der auswertung von preis
von comics beträgt das durchschnittliche
alter der todesopfer durch self 21 jahre
wobei die beiden jüngsten toten erst 14
jahre alt waren und es lässt sich noch
mal herausfinden rund 75 prozent der
toten sind männlich zwar machen frauen
im schnitt mehr saves allerdings lägen
sie anscheinend eher weniger wert auf
ein spektakuläres sättigen forscher an
der universität von ohio haben
herausgefunden dass männer die
regelmäßig saves machen in
persönlichkeitstest er merkmale von
narzissmus und psychopathie zeigen
damit würde auch die bereitschaft für
riskante aktionen steigen
wissenschaftler des fox beschreibt es so
zitat es dreht sich alles um mich es
geht darum mich ins richtige licht zu
rücken ich bekomme aufmerksamkeit wenn
ich das auch social media plattform
mache bekomme ich von den leuten die
bestätigung die ich brauche das ich
großartig bin zitat ende
durch das zusammenspiel mehrerer
statistische auswertung ist es also
möglich situationen einschätzen zu
können bei unserem beispiel also wer
sich für ein cf in gefahr bringt in
russland nimmt man die gefahr inzwischen
der riskanten fotografien scheinbar sehr
ernst und hat schon verbotsschilder
erstellt in disneyland in paris sind
safesticks aus sicherheitsgründen
verboten worden
auch indien hat reagiert in mumbai
wurden ebenfalls warnschilder
aufgestellt und sogar
mehr rettungsschwimmer eingestellt
außerdem soll an mehreren plätzen das
schießen von cfs verboten werden in
deutschland gibt es noch keine direkten
cfw verbote nur safestick sind zum
beispiel in manchen museen verboten
wobei ich glaube das hat weniger mit
lebensgefahr zu tun bei uns gab es
allerdings auch noch keine toten durch
cfs es ist schon faszinierend was man
anhand einer statistik über eine
nachricht wie mehr tote durch saves als
durch hai attacken herausfinden kann
dank statistik erfährt man viel mehr
über die hintergründe und es wird auch
möglich etwas gegen den grassierenden
self die tote in unserem fall zu
unternehmen denn sind wir mal ehrlich
für ein tolles elfi sollte man sich
nicht in lebensgefahr bringen seid ihr
schon mal für 111 ein risiko eingegangen
oder haltet ihr es sowieso eher für
überflüssig sich die ganze zeit selbst
abzulichten schreibt uns eure meinung in
die kommentare last einen daumen nach
oben da wenn euch das video gefallen hat
und abonniert den kanal ist er kostenlos
nicht vergessen nächstes video schauen
ist er mindestens spannend wie das hier
und bis dann bleibt dran